so so here let's let's do this let's
jump right over to the to the next bit
we have a tweet from mr count dankula oh
yeah countdankel is awesome
by the way i hope you guys uh follow him
he says twitter just did a mass banning
of parody accounts that make fun of far
left rhetoric
but none of the accounts that mock
right-wing rhetoric
so first this is this was before all
this went down
pro-trump pundit permanently suspended
from twitter
the conservative pundit bill mitchell
has been permanently suspended
from the social media platform and this
is confirmed to the hill
mitchell has been permanently suspended
for violating the twitter rules
by using one account to evade the
suspension of another account
a twitter spokesperson said in an email
mitchell confirmed a suspension in a
post on social media app
parlor though he asserted he was booted
from twitter over his stance on wearing
a mask amid the chronovirus pandemic
twitter just suspended me for opposing
masks who knows if i'll ever be back
mitchell said
i'm sure the decision wasn't political
at all i have a quick question for you
you run a company so i'm sure you have a
legal department
if you accused somebody of doing a thing
for which you banned them and it was not
true
you clearly faced legal liability right
like if you said i we we banned tim
poole for manipulating the platform with
multiple accounts
and i didn't do that you're lying it's
like just like slander libel defamation
yeah i mean we could
get into some of the patreon lawsuit
that i mean well i mean why is that
getting no attention
the patreon law school yeah i think
we're waiting for i've seen not a single
major article about that this is bad
news for patreon
yeah because they're based in california
i mean i not a single
mainstream article about it of course
it's silicon valley they're in trouble
they're it's their own rules
you know yeah well but we'll we'll see
you in the i mean there was the
uh the daily dot cover for those that
aren't familiar with what happened
patreon
got sued uh uh they there was a request
request
for arbitration because they banned
people then they sued those people
trying to stop this because they would
have to front millions of dollars
they lost the suit and have to front
millions of dollars
and now because of this it sparked a big
wave of attention it was a huge mistake
stressing effect
they're getting a wave of people like
sargon lauren southern it's you know a
couple other people
all of their fans are now going after
patreon patrons have to front what 10
20 30 40 50 who knows how many millions
but
the reason i ask you this specifically
is twitter likes to play these games in
my opinion i don't know if it's true or
not
when they suspend people and say
something like
you know uh this person was using
multiple accounts
but if they're not really yeah like how
do we know how do
we know that's true there's no i want to
see proof you know what i mean yeah i
think there would be grounds for
legal action and that's why you need to
provide a path
to redemption and that's why we rolled
out the jury system to keep ourselves in
check in case we make mistakes people
can
appeal it to the jury on mines and it's
just like
you make mistakes but there's no talking
to a human
at twitter or facebook when you get
banned i mean for some people there is
for some people yeah yep if if you are
wealthy
successful famous you're a big media
company you pick up that phone number
your friend's a moderator yup yeah and
and is that
incestrous
so you know what uh jack actually talked
about a path to redemption
along jack dorsey of twitter a long time
ago because the
uh the way it's explained right let's
say you're on twitter
people use this to connect with
politicians you know their local their
local council things like this
and you say a naughty word that you
didn't realize was a bad word like
hashtag learn to code or something
now you're banned forever you can never
open a new account you can never use the
platform again
that's like a digital death sentence
from minor infraction
so you know jack dorsey's talked about a
path to redemption
they've never done anything not that i
know of you guys have a jury system on
mines
yeah yeah what does that do yeah
basically if
you get tagged or you know flagged on
sfw
and you think that it was wrong then it
goes to a randomized
group of 12 active users we are thinking
about expanding that number
to make it a little bit less um
to make their less potential for
abuse but yeah it goes to 12 active
users they vote and it can get
overturned and and
you can go and check the analytics and
you know we've been we've made some
mistakes but people got back
yeah yeah i remember like around the
time you implemented there were people
accusing you of bias for banning them
they didn't even get banned they got
flagged on sfw because
oh something and then they but you can't
even get banned for
posting nsfw content on mines you can
get your channel marked which
in order that we want nsfw content but
we need to be able to put blurs in order
to have that so that
people who don't want to see that aren't
seeing it anyway i
actually i did a live stream with this
one guy uh acts
17 apologetic youtube channel and he he
criticizes
islam and he said
you know he was sensational on purpose
when it happened and he sort of knew and
he said he was going to come back and he
was cool but you know i understand
people are sensitive like
for especially for platforms who say
that they're free speech focused
and then for bannings to happen like
that's definitely scary so i you know
straight up if something happens to you
on mines or someone you know
on their channel has happened just email
info mines.com
we'll work it out we'll we'll try to
figure it out i get emails all the time
from people
they're like tim you complain about
censorship why won't you promote minds
and bitshoot
and i'm like i promote mines well bill's
here now so bill promote mines
uh yeah the jury system i think was
really really smart i remember when you
told me you were rolling it out
this way if something happens it's like
it was on 12 random users
yeah necessarily you guys and and the
the mandate is to vote
with the first amendment based policy
not to just vote on your opinion
yeah so you know but i'm sure a lot of
people some people can try to game it
and
that's what's probably happening but you
just have to make a good faith effort
this is why i think you should you
should expand it to a lot more people
how many
i don't know 100 a thousand depends on
how many active users you can pester
you know what i mean but you know the
thing is what happens if it's just a bad
day and you get six random
bad people it's a lot easier to get bad
people when you have a smaller pool
it's much easier to avoid that but
there's a couple other things i want to
highlight real quick too so we can you
know we could talk more about this
the daily caller reported many reported
reported the babylon bee
so this is in line with what count
dankula was saying channels that
mock the left and i mean the babylon b
is general satire
and parody it's not even necessarily
just targeting left though it kind of is
they're technically a christian site
right right yeah
and then we have uh kyle mann he
confirmed it for
spam and manipulation and that's really
really weird but
they were brought back they say we're
back twitter destroyed our headquarters
with a drone strike
but we are being assured it was an
honest mistake i love it
it's fantastic yeah so uh we also have
tatania mcgrath
check this out uh are you familiar with
titania titania i always thought it was
titania it's titania titanium yeah named
for what was it named for the
queen of the fairies yeah didn't you say
that a bookstore just mistakenly yeah
yeah that was so good so uh titania
is locked now you gotta you know you've
gotta click accept actually i'm pretty
sure
oh actually i don't know if titania
actually has the uh
the the photo of the bookstore
but there is yeah yeah okay james
yeah it was because they got locked out
james james posted it here's andrew
doyle who runs it he says
it looks as though it was titania
mcgrath's threat about medical science
that got her locked out of twitter
all i was doing was satirizing the
tortious logic of critical theory
and how it promotes dangerous ideas in
the name of social justice
how is that worthy of a ban because
they've banned a bunch of party accounts
it would seem like they're going after
them you know what i think it is
the longest time the meme was quote the
left can't mean
all of a sudden now there's a there's a
reddit forum called the right can't mean
and it mocks these fake memes that like
just not real
like somebody's purposely making bad
memes that attack the left to blame the
right
when an mit technology review story and
study
found that the donald and 4chan were the
most prolific
generators of memes yet all of a sudden
now it's being reversed
so they're banning right-wing parody
accounts
satire is crucial man
i'll die without it well you know what
some people say is that
ridicule is one of the most effective
weapons
dude if you there's no point to the
internet
without comedy i mean i guess commerce
well yeah no i yeah thank you
thank you i can order i can order my uh
my underwear off amazon
but uh but no jokes that's too far
yeah we'll go ahead so do you think this
is just the next step in their prep for
november
do you think that if we remove a little
bit do you think people will stop
noticing that the comedy is only coming
from the right if they nuke some of
these satire sites
and why did they let the babylon be back
up do you think
because i really don't know i mean it's
just arbitrary
it seems and there's no consistency so
we have no idea what's going on and
you know tim knows better than anybody i
mean he grilled them
himself and oh yeah i love round two
there's
we need wraps yeah seriously what
follow-up was there
um a single thing periodically
like i'll have a conversation with jack
and he just
you know he's like he's like uh
i don't know describe it he's just
abusive
you know he whispers all these sweet
nothings into your ear he massages your
shoulders he's emotionally abusive and
he's like no no it's okay it's okay
we're gonna we're gonna fix the platform
come on just come back
i i won't i won't suspend you again i
won't ban your friends i won't shut you
down
it was a mistake it was a mistake i
promise every single time but the policy
hasn't
changed nothing's changed it's gotten
worse now no they're they're trying to
ban
you know satire i think you know
i think we have a hysteria problem in
this country
that's where i think it's coming from i
think it has to do with the algorithms i
think the algorithms it's really funny
that
we started seeing this phenomenon and
maybe you know about more about this
than i do where it polarized everybody
oh so all of a sudden there was no
middle ground anymore it was all either
super left or super right
you know then they banned all of the far
right
so now everyone kind of moved over to a
center right position they don't get
banned
so it's far left and center right yep
they are
engineering polarization radicalization
extremism
like and i think they know it
because there's data scientists who work
there and there's dozens of
studies about how censorship increases
violence
increases radicalization so they act
like they're being
moral crusaders but they are
creating extremists and now
i'll you know keep myself in check and
say obviously people can get radicalized
on social media and people do
get you know whether it's um
islamic propaganda and whatever it is
kkk
but you need the open forum in order to
give people no one is changing their
mind if you kick them off it's not
happening
right they will never change so that's
pretty much the end of the argument
yeah they can't ever get better so you
have to think of it more
from like a mental health perspective
i don't know man they just they're
they're so powerful
and they know this information then
they're doing it on purpose they're
doing on purpose
so what is it they're trying to win an
election but it
yeah and like the weird thing is if you
look at google or i mean or twitter
because they have different policies in
different countries
so you know the twitter policy in
pakistan is totally different it's way
more restrictive than the twitter policy
in the us and you know they're all like
oh well we won't go into china
you know google won't won't buckle for
china but google is buckling for all of
these other
countries yeah super oppressive laws
so it's just and google search has
totally different
censorship policies than youtube and
it's like what
yeah i'm censored on google my
main channels you cannot google search
this channel however you can
yes it's almost like it was on purpose
that we made a new channel weird
if you if you search for tim cast like
my actual channel
you can take this is the craziest thing
you can take the full title of any one
of my main channel videos from
youtube.comcast
put the url in google and facebook comes
up
because i upload also to facebook the
facebook url gets displayed on google
not youtube now how does that make sense
maybe maybe now they're going to be like
there's no there's no trust problem here
you know you don't need to break up the
company see
we're promoting a competitor yeah
through search
yeah tim cast news and tim cast won't
appear tim cast irl does
and it's happened to a lot of other
channels around the time we all started
getting smeared
the left i in my opinion i think many of
these
people in media know full well exactly
what's going on
there's a radicalization initially i
think because of facebook
a radicalization into in both directions
but there's very few
like real you know i'm quote-unquote
far-right people
in the u.s in this you know thousands of
millions and i noticed
one of the things that happens when you
start to isolate all the right wing
people is that they just find the little
corners that make them happy
and they go off and found people who
think just like them and that is
that's dangerous like i really don't
like the idea of pushing someone off a
public platform so they can go find
people who think just like them
yeah you know i mean they don't care
about the internet the internet is
they the extremists the the big tech
censorship platforms i mean the you have
to think of the internet as
a community it's not i mean it's a it's
a finite
space so they know what's going on
and they're just playing games and
honestly they they will
probably i feel like inevitably there
the data is going to prove this that
they're engineering radicalization on
purpose
uh or it or accidentally maybe some
people on purpose maybe not i don't want
to speculate about
like how malicious it is maybe they're
doing it with good intentions but just
and the people making decisions don't
have
an understanding of the data or maybe
they're too scared to face it like what
would it be like
if facebook and youtube just suddenly
started
allowing like super radical content with
the understanding that like put it this
way
you take 50 000 content moderators that
each of these companies have
instead of having them just go ban crazy
every day
have them actually be reaching out to
people and talking to people
and like engaging in conversation guess
what it takes 10 years to de-radicalize
somebody
but is that that like a study confirmed
10 years or something oh no
well i mean we are just giving up i mean
that daryl would say daryl davis
would say that it takes years i mean i
don't think that there's a set amount of
time it could probably could be faster
or slower
for different people but just imagine
like tens of thousands of
of moderators actually trying to help
people
what's interesting is they're the the
more extreme ban happy
platforms i feel like make huge mistakes
they lose all leverage
you know there was uh uh you're familiar
with sargon of akkad yeah
he's uh for those that aren't i assume
many of you are he's a youtube
commentator
and he spoke on a stream you know like
early 2018 or something it was a small
channel
he ironically used the n-word to make a
point
about people he thought were racist and
so
a year later like nine nine months later
somebody
shows that in the middle of a two-hour
you know
live stream in a small channel within a
few thousand views patreon nukes him
instantly
and i was like if patreon just gave him
a warning
then they could have been like hey don't
do it again sorry i would have been like
okay
that would have been it he'd be like oh
yeah i was trying to make a point i get
it i won't do it instead
they terminate his income and so when i
was when i was you know talking to the
company to patreon i'm like
why would you do that it's
counterproductive you you're
guaranteeing these people can only go in
one direction
you know my thing is like if someone is
is behaving in a certain way
what twitter is doing is actually kind
of scary there's it's social
manipulation it's mass social
engineering
they tell people here's what isn't is
and isn't acceptable
and then the scared people who don't
want to lose their followers fall in
line
and won't say naughty things i got no
problem tweeting articles from
dr harvey rich md phd of yale when he
you know uh when he talks well of
hydroxychloroquine
and i've done several videos on that
stuff and i know that's a ban hammer
but i have a line you know what i mean
i'm not going to let them keep pushing
and pushing and pushing
because what ends up happening is the
more censorship we have like this
the more we end up with people who only
speak about the other side
that's what i was saying before so
basically you look at covid there was a
story did you i don't know if you heard
this
what was it the department of natural
resources or something yeah i think so
they told people to wear masks when
they're on zoom calls
even if they're home alone right it's
like why
for show exactly for show
how did 15 days to slow the spread turn
into 15 times 10.133 days to slow the
spread
so far because anyone who says anything
like
okay was that enough shut down the media
won't allow it
general our culture doesn't allow it i'm
not sure it's on purpose man
to be honest to a certain degree i think
so i think
we're trapped in a hysterical mob
running around with pitchforks and you
can't reason with anybody
do you think people who wear masks in
their car driving
are mostly doing it because they're
actually
scared or because they're trying to
signal both people yeah both i think
it's both
yeah i mean to be fair i'm sure
someone's seen me driving i had my mask
on
because like when we go out and i'm like
we're like a block out from the
walgreens or whatever
i just i just put yeah it's like gear up
mask on
just like that yeah put the vast you
know strap
all the good stuff it's super cool i
just put the mask on because you know i
put the put over my ears and then like
about to get out of the car
comfortable in it but i've seen people
driving on the highway with masks on
and then i'm just kind of like no no i
don't get that
i think joe was with joe rogan was
racking on it they got made fun of for
it
i think i figured it out i think people
are just lazy and they just don't want
to take it off
between trips or whatever i think it's
weird i find it uncomfortable
i got no problem wearing them but anyway
the point is not to get into a big mass
conversation like i got no problem
wearing a mask
someone sent me this really cool mask
out of beanie yeah it's so cool a little
beanie beanie on the mask
yeah but go ahead no well i was going to
rewrite my point to kind of get back on
track it's that
when you see 10 articles per day
the end is nigh the end is nigh the end
is nine and then you see one article on
the right pop up saying perhaps the end
is not so nigh as we first thought
banned
then the only thing anybody sees is the
end is nigh then the next states the end
is nair
and the next day it's the nist and this
is it this is the end
so now we're on day 152 since donald
trump tweeted out
15 days to slow the spread because you
can't challenge
the the mob i think what we might be
seeing
is that these big social media companies
facebook twitter even youtube
they're beholden to the mob the same as
everybody else not realizing
they're the biggest players in directing
it you know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode